everyone for attending uh my talk uh my
name is shillong liu
i'm a professor at the university of
colorado school of medicine
i'm also a founder and president of
summit bowler
which is a university startup
focusing on saliva diagnostics for
cancer and infectious disease
um for the next 30 minutes talk uh
i hope that i can convince you
the advantages of using saliva in
clinical testing for cancer and
infectious disease
specifically for those disease derived
from the
quote-unquote upper error disaster tract
the uadt
and this diagram actually is described
as the anatomic location of uadt
as shown here that you know this
includes
all the parts above your neck they have
the nose or cavities through the larynx
and down to esophagus bronchi and lung
and for the nose throat oral calcium
larynx
in clinically cancer derived from those
reasons cause a head and neck cancer
the other part of the a
upper air disaster track is infectious
disease and the most common disease is
the respiratory infections
such as the coenanting and flu
so then i think uh in my talk i
basically have a two parts the first
part i will talk about etching clear
which is a saliva based test for head
and neck cancer
i'm going to talk those from our lab
invention
to clinical validation and medication
and the second part
i'm going to talk about what we have
contributed uh in fighting the pandemic
talk about the co-way fast which is the
rna traction free method
using either saliva or swab
and also i'm gonna share our real world
experience
for using those tests
in
kobe tech colorado which is the main
drug for the
coe testing efforts in state of colorado
so first let's talk about the head and
neck cancer
nearly over 90 percent of the head and
neck cancer are squamous cell carcinoma
and it's been depending on the location
it's roughly classified as three major
scc or ie squamous cell carcinoma
so is the
oral cavity or called oral fcc and
oropharyngeal fcc and larenzo scc
so it's the seven most common cancer in
u.s
but the prevalence or the survivors
actually rank even higher than this
incidence is the third i most common
with the cancer survivors in u.s
and the smoking and drinking occupied
of the
etiological factors of discarding
particularly in the scc from oral cavity
and the larynx
a recently the hpv infection
contributes a significant portion of
head and neck cancer
particularly in the oropharyngeal
scc
so similar to other cancers 5-year
survival is a highly associated with the
disease you identify
and unfortunately
most of the patients when they diagnose
they're already in advanced stage
and over 30 percent of the patients will
have a recur of the cancer come back
within two years
so it's clearly the
medical need for early detection of head
and neck cancer
when well it still allow more treatment
plan
so this slides showing the advantages of
saliva over blood for headache cancer
detection
you may heard a lot about liquid biopsy
but most of the liquid valves are
block-based
but actually showing in this diagram you
can see
for a cancer being detectable in the
blood vessel
cancers need to progress to a certain
state which allow them to cross or
invade the tissue boundaries and get
into the blood vessel
given saliva uh
anatomical proximity
to head neck cancer
you're able to detect head and neck
cancer while it's in a very early stage
which is still in the local or called in
situ stage
the current standard care for head and
cancer include physical examination such
as the palpation
[Music]
doctor may do some
scopey detection
and imaging include pet scan mri
uh while
in the suspicious re
area they always do the
so the saliva test comparing to those
standard care at least benefit from both
the patient experience and the
clinically
given saliva classes convenience
non-invasive nature and less expensive
than imaging
it will predict to significantly improve
the patient compliance for their
follow-up which is one of the limiting
factors for
improving the
survival
the other part is the clinical benefits
since we have those multiple times
testing you can able to detect the
cancers earlier than the standard care
which results a time shifting
this one has potentially increased the
state shifting which we can do more
curative treatment instead of just
pitiful treatment
which will ultimately lead to a survival
improvement
in addition
based on the saliva test you can do the
individualized surveillance plan and
also based on the marker you can do the
precision treatment
so next few slides is our data for the
etching here
and this slide just summarize how we
start
so the biomarkers uh we are using for
hepatic cancer is a combination of a dna
methylation
and the microrna
so
by browsing the genome for the genomic
loci for micro rna
we identify the cpg island which has the
potential to be a bowel marker
and then we go through the thyroid
tissues and the saliva
in the end the markers
is composed with the seven
methylation genomic loci for macro rna
which we called mg mere and will also
validate those markup performance in
about 300
cases of tissues and 200 cases of saliva
so this is the uh summary of the roc
curve for individual markers
and together with the composition of the
seven markers together
from both the tissue and a and saliva in
b
so on the left side you see the roc
curve you see the a composition of the
seven markers give the best roc curve
compared to the individual markers
on the right side of the table
this is the random forest analysis
which rank the market performance
and also include demographic information
such as age and smoking status
these two tables summarize a our
performance for sensitivity and
specificity in tissue on left side and
saliva on right side
this has been done with the logistic
regression
you can see in the red box in a combined
one
the sensitivity and specificity in
tissues are all about 90 percent
while in saliva the sensitivity is
merely reached 85
while the specificity is 95 percent
on the combined qis we include age as
additional factors and you can see that
include a's do not contribute
significantly
of the marker performance
we then use the assay i just remind
again assay we called it and clear
performance to correlate with the
clinical testological factors
so the first is we want to see whether
they have a differences between the
different location
like oral cavity aurofengio and rivangio
and they the essence clear basically
detect equally on those three different
type of the head neck cancer
the acid tends to detect more spv
positive cases than neptune cases
as shown in the lower of the left table
more importantly the assay can detect
tumors when tumors are still very small
like the t1 states
or no
node metastasis at n0 and also stage one
so this slides um give a more
magnetic view or biology of action clear
testing and how we're going to define
those tasks in the clinical application
so
similar to the a
collagen regulation
the dna methylation is also strongly
regulated microrna
and
i'll just remind everyone microrna is a
normal class of the molecule which is a
a very potent molecule to regulate
its target genes expression through
bonding to the three ogr
i'm showing here in a normal situation
on the left side while no major
methylation happens in the cpg iron
the micron a1 can express in the certain
level which can regulate or inhibit the
oncogene a make it silencing in the
normal cells
while when the hypermethylation happen
in the cpg island
it will reduce or silence the microrna 1
which will reduce the inhibition of
regulation on oncogene a will cause
oncogene activation and cause the cancer
cell drought
so you can see that we have three ways
to
application of this
microrna can on use as a diagnostic
purpose and know so we can use this as a
companion biomarker for bell farmers
and last you can even deliver the
macaroni mimic
to as a therapeutic approach
so this slide summarize our a data on
functional characterization of the
microrna for head and neck cancer
on the very left uh slides this showing
the methylation level are highly
associated with the expression level
methylation level sowing on the top and
the expression level showing on the
bottom
the middle uh
figure showing when we deliver the
micron a mimics
it can significantly inhibit the cell
proliferation
and also reduce uh sphere forming in c
and a set population size in d
so both c and d are markers for cancer
stem cells in head neck cancer
and on the very right
we also found and validate a molecule
called ezhq as downstream target for the
microrna the ech2 is also very potent
regulator for cancer stem cells in head
neck
so um this slides basically summarize
based on the nccn guideline for what
current a a treatment plan
and neck cancer while the lower yellow
part is our predict estrogen clear has
potential in the clinical utilities
so depending on the stage
you have net cancer either undergoing
surgeries or radiation therapies
and the
chemotherapies
the etching clear can fit into all three
different states as pre-treatment
for the clinical outcome prediction
or the post treatment to see the
treatment response and also on the
follow-up to see whether you can find
the recurrence earlier and improving the
clinical outcome
so this is the data for our
pre-treatment stratification use asking
etching clear
in saliva and tissue can clearly see
that it can clear can separate the
preterm patient into high and low risk
for their progression-free survival
based on the markers
and this slide showed
before and post treatment
the marker levels
at the post treatment are highly
associated with clinical outcomes such
as the recurrence and death
last this is a some pilot data for our
longitudinal study for head neck cancer
you can see that in 14 patients who had
a recur or death
13 a test positive action clear
in contrast with 29 patients has no
recurrence 23 are test negative
so there are still six uh patient test
positives and will currently follow up
those patients for their clinical
outcome
and the right table
basically a few examples to show
the top five uh marker or etching clear
positive correlates with the recurrence
while the lower five uh test negative
correlates with the
a recurrence negative
most importantly if you look at it in
c16 patient
the lead time for the saliva test for
etching the etching clears the level
test as positive has
336 days lead time i had with the
imaging for
detect the recurrence
so the current ongoing clinical trial
has been
uh doing
um for
item clearing in handmade cancer uh as a
headache here we're aiming to i
evaluate whether etching clear
is compatible or non-inferred relative
to the medical imaging and also using
those we can being finalized the
clinical trials of validate etching
clear can really detect cancer earlier
than current clinical practice
so that's my first part of talk about
the cancer piece and now move to the
infectious disease part uh and here is a
specific a on code
so this slide summarized what we have
contributed to a source curve to
detection we have a four iep
uh from cu summit biolab and washu i
will briefly go through with you about
the four different
a a
a test application
invented uh through this joint a
collaboration
uh code way fast is extraction-free
method
workfast is the proxy pcr for variant of
concern for codeword
kodi clear is the assay developed for
very low monitoring
and sweet and swab is the new acid
combination with both saliva and swab
the first is the kobe fast which is a
extraction-free covenanting test
highly accurate rapid and low cost
so depending on the
sample
either you use those straw
for saliva connection or you use this
swab with a proximal breakpoint for swap
the reason we're using this as you saw
yes you see the yellow tubes is later we
can all move this sample collection into
a two mil crowd valve which fits our
high throughput detection workflow
and the survivor fast is the most
accurate direct pcr syllabu test while
the swap fast by using our proprietary
wireless transfer buffer this is the
first director pcr nasal swap test
and
as i mentioned at the beginning uh work
with the uh kobe check colorado
by august 28 we have done uh 87 000
tests already uh for people in colorado
and we found the positive rate about 5.6
percent
so
next few slides i'm showing you the
analytical validation for our expression
free
method in both saliva and as well
as you see in this table
figure a and b
basically there are no differences for
the ct
when you comparing the assay with and
the result
rna traction
this is has been done in analytical well
level using the control sample
this is also an analytical validation
for a standard curve and also the limit
of detection lod
so the lod for both
saliva fats and swat fast is a four copy
per microliter
this slides is the clinical validation
using the clinical sample you see that
a and b is the saliva with the swap
and they
with and without our extraction
basically there are no differences for
the in one detection demonstrate a
extraction free masses is at least
equivalent to the rna extraction method
so the second is the workfast
basically is a proxy pcr for variant of
concern
and we all know that now is
predominant about delta variant but back
to may
the variance of concern or voc
leased on the cdc website are alpha beta
and gamma variants and we have developed
proxy pcr specifically detached for
those
vlc
so first we want to see that all those
three variants won't affect our
performance uh as a wild type so showing
here for the four different
uh
positive controls uh the three variants
comparing to well type there are no
performance difference based on the
variance
for our coefficient detection
we then uh design a primers and process
specifically for those voc detection and
this is the analytical validation
the top panel on a is
the validation of the four
different primer sets to detect their
both on the b1 and 7 positive control
versus the wild type
so the primary and probe set
for earn is eliminated because these
primers
have a non-specific amplification
would one detect a wild type when the
copy numbers over at ten thousand
so we then use our
and the s1 primers to do a variance
separation as you see that all primers
basically can screen all the three
variants together
b117351 and p1 while the s1 primers can
separate
b117 from the other two values
so
this is our proxy pcr we then send our
samples to
bioshock which is a ngs a company
in a black fashion for the validation of
our proxy pcr
and you can see here that while in the
12 positive cases for both orf and s1
nds results confirm there are all b1 and
7 variants
and for the two samples one is worth
positive while s1 negative
the sub the the nds results showing one
is one one sb ah one three five one
and for the remaining next tubes for
both r or s1 the ngs sodium none of them
are the three vocs
shown here so the core coordinates for
the voc
positive and the net 2 for voc is 100
so this is just the
period of time we're using this proxy
pcr
by
the end of may 2022
uh you see that the weekly voc incidents
using our profit tcr is gradually
increased but after may
we stopped doing the variant detection
with more of the delta variance
appearing and right now being
delta variance being pretty dominant
over rest of the variance
so the third is a we also developed in a
assay we call it a kovic here
for a very low monitoring and i'm going
to show you some data for our
longitudinal study
we have over 200 time points of sample
collection from 19 codeword positive
patients
this is the one example of patient 35
you see the red dot it's just using the
swap sample while the grain is using
saliva samples
and we have the patient collect a
morning and the afternoon for both uh uh
twice collection a day um this is over
24 days uh with all different time
points you see that the general training
for the patients is definitely a
decrease uh in
when we're comparing suave with
satellite you see at the
early of the outside
you see more viral load in the
swap
comparing to the saliva
but in the middle of the course or
sometimes a saliva will be more
i detect more very low than swap
so this is the statistical composition
of all mounting
[Music]
positive patients over 200 time points
sample pounding together you see the red
is the
saliva while the
uh let me see clearly
um
yeah and
the uh blue is
the saliva and the red is the swap
you see that
as
what we reflect on the patient one at
the beginning you just see more uh very
low detection on swap while
when it goes to day 10 you see basically
the swab and saliva tests about equally
of detection of the very load
which also showing on the right side of
this table basically showing the
differences of the ct you see higher on
the
any of the testing before 10 days but
after 10 days they're about the same
we're also comparing uh saliva tia with
a saliva fast which basically is another
clinical validation for iron extraction
versus rna non-extraction
uh you see that in both cases uh the
both tests in saliva has a very good
alignment
in terms of the test performance and
this is also being statistically
validated
in the table shown on the right you see
that the differences between those cts
are almost keep to zero or no
differences along the disease course
and finally as they pointed out that you
know a depending on the days and the
patients sometimes you detect them more
in saliva sometimes because more in
swath
so we then think to pull them together
combination of the saliva and swap which
we have those called speed and swap
assay which you can see that these and
fiber say significantly improve the ct
values comparing to survival alone
so in summary i hope that i can convince
you that saliva is really ideal about
space month for a cancer detections or
infectious disease for those cancer
derived from uadt
ie head and neck esophagus in the lung
and also for the respiratory infection
on uat such as a cognitive
i'd like to acknowledge the people from
my lab and and my colleague at the
university of colorado for clinical
support
pathological clear lab consulting and
about statistical analysis
uh thank you for the summit biolabs
offering this uh real world clinical
testing
with our team and advisors and our
collaborator at washiu hsu md anderson
and also the belsha for validating our
proxy pcr
um in the end also would like to thank
my i research support
from nih
or state
funding
institution funding and private
foundation support
thank you